was machen die personen
sie spielen instrumente sie machen musik
er spielt gitarre
[Applaus]
sie spielt schlagzeug
er spielt geige
sie spielt saxophon
was machen die personen
sie machen sport
er spielt fußball sie spielt basketball
er spielt golf er macht krafttraining
sie macht yoga
sie rennt
trainiert
er schwimmt was machen die personen
sie spielen sie spielen mit der puppe er
spielt videogames er spielt billard
er spielt mit dem auto
sie spielt karten er spielt mit dem hund
spielen
ich spiele du spielst er sie es spielt
wir spielen ihr spielt sie spielen
machen
ich mache du machst er sie es macht wir
machen ihr macht sie machen trainieren
ich trainiere du trainierst er sie es
trainiert wir trainieren ihr trainiert
sie trainieren
lernen ich lerne
du lernst er sie es lehrt wir lernen
hier lernt sie lernen kochen
ich koche du kochst er sie es kocht wir
kochen ihr kocht sie kochen schwimmen
ich schwimme du schwimmst er sie es
schwimmt wir schwimmen
hier schwimmt sie schwimmen rennen
ich renne du rennst er sie es rennt wir
rennen ihr rennt sie rennen
[Musik]